welcome back to 8701
so in this lecture we look at the
interaction of w
codons with quarks so the charged weak
interaction of quarks
let's just make a number of observations
so we observe that the weak interaction
respects the lepton generation
meaning that a w couples to an electron
and an electro neutrino
but not an electron in the mirena too
but
in the case of the quarks there is a
violation of this
so there is a disrespect of the clock
generation
when it comes to the interaction with ws
so when you investigate these two
diagrams here you find that the w
couples couples to the u-quark but to
the b quark and the u-quark but it also
couples to the s-code
s clock in the youth block all right
um in order to encapsulate this we have
to make a correction and the corrections
are typically called
cosine um theta c and sine theta c
theta c is a cabinet angle so theta
cable
turns out this is rather small certain
decrease so it is a correction of small
correction when we study the
partial decay with of the k on that in
electronic decays
um was a partial decays to the ion of
the occupier in electronic decays
we found that there is a set of forms
that was a form factor for the pi and
decay and a form factor for the k on
decay
it turns out that the form factors are
due to
this additional correction so you find
the tangent square of the carbido angle
as part of this correction good
so far so good now we have made an
observation we haven't explained
anything yet
you can make one more um observation or
discuss
one and that's the decay of neutral
chaons to a pair of neurons it turns out
that
those are not very likely
even so you would expect that the
amplitude has a factor here
of um sine and cosine tabito
so the amplitude should be in the order
of sine
theta carbido times cosine theta
[Music]
um so when this was studied the charm
clock hasn't been discovered
um and the explanation to why
uh this decay is suppressed comes from
the fact that there is a second diagram
here
where we just replace the u chord in
this loop as a c clock
this diagram contributes as a minus sign
to the amplitude and therefore those two
diagrams they cancel
right yeah they are the same magnitude
about the same magnitude and we have an
opposite side
so this was the first indication that
there must be a fourth quark
contributing to this kind of processes
the charm block
um let me now try to understand what's
going on here why is the w
uh coupling modified um or why
it's not the full down quark or
a strange core participating in the weak
interaction
um we can do the following here we can
rewrite
or we note that the the weak interaction
eigenstate the eigenstate which
participate in the weak index is not the
eigenstate of the particle itself the
so-called mass eigenstate
so we have to write the weak eigenstate
with a linear combination of the
the mass eigenstate or white version
this can be done
in this matrix form here where we simply
modify
multiply the weak eigenstates
with the with a matrix and just
basically rotate it
into the mass eigenstate so this was
proposed by gabibo and rather successful
um but it didn't incorporate the search
innovation articles and this was done by
kobayashi and mascara who generalized
the scheme
and propose the so-called ckm matrix c
is here for
cabibo kobayashi and mascara
because of constraints we'll discuss in
[Music]
in one of the recitations um this matrix
can be parameterized or has only
three independent angles and one complex
space as independent parameters
so you can choose different
parameterization to capture that there's
only three
four parameters in this matrix which has
nine components um one is
by uh thinking about this matrix as
three independent rotations in this
complex space here
in terms of numerical values you see
that the
diagonal elements of this matrix are
very close to one
meaning that this this mixing is
for in the dwark sector the wireless
mount effect you find that those next
nearest
off diagonal elements and the order of
20 percent
and the next to next of elements are
even
smaller okay this leads us
into the discussion that we can you know
use different parameterization in order
to capture
we already discussed the standard
parameterization which you can really
think about
three different rotations um and the
the values of this those angles are
given here
together with the value of this um
additional phase
another way to look at this is the
so-called wolfenstein polarization and
this captures the fact that it seems
like that there is a
correction being applied to the actual
particle so you find
elements the order of lambda lambda is
about 22
um then you find elements which are in
the order of one minus
the lambda square correction and then
there's elements which are of lambda
square and lambda
third power so this captures
the matrix and then there's higher order
corrections to that
which are of order lambda to the fourth
power
okay
um because there's constraints on this
matrix
specifically your unitarity constraints
meaning that
you know we have three generations if i
make a mixing of those three
uh mass eigenstate to a weak eigenstate
then
on you know unitarily the the total
number of
particles in this discussion is
conserved uh this will change if there
would be for example a fourth generation
particle
so the study of weak charge interaction
with quark helps us to understand
whether or not there might be a fourth
generation
um we'll not go into too much detail
here but it also the the
complex space um explains part of
uh our understanding of cp violation
and we might discuss it in a little bit
of a later of a later lecture
but nevertheless so what we can actually
form here is those unitarity constraints
just simply summing over the matrix
elements
the scalar product of matrix elements
and those where
the contribution vanishes vanishes so
those where
j and k are not equal those um
can be represented as a triangle that's
quite interesting you can just rewrite
this
you just say for those three elements of
the sum are equal to zero
then you normalize by one element in
this case here
normalized by uh vcd
vcb and so then this makes this point
being zero
and so we have this nice triangle here
which has
three angles alpha data and gamma
and this point here rho and eta
and so this is a nice way to illustrate
actual measurements of the elements
of this ckm metric of the ckm matrix
element
and without actually explaining how we
do this experiment you can assume that
you know all measurements have or you
can understand that all measurements
have
to do with the weak interaction with
kwarf that's how we have access
to the um speaker and matrix elements
uh sometimes this results in
modification of
masses or splitting of mass states and
sometimes the direct measurement
of the coupling
when you put all of those measurements
back together you can
look at this so we see on our triangle
here
we see this this point um
etc and row which is given here in this
plane and you see various number of
measurements
um which cause branch to um
which corresponds to you know elements
of this
of the cklm metrics